I want to move on to something else that
popped up in my timeline this week that
I think is relevant
um and we're going to be talking about
the women again which is 50's favorite
topic uh let me put it up on the screen
uh because this is some biblical level
of brattiness I mean I've seen a lot of
a lot of bratty stuff it looks like this
girl is trying to do a story or some
kind of social media post well I'll just
play it like you guys can see this uh
let me know if the audio doesn't play
when I put this up on the screen but I I
think it's set to play so just have a
listen to this the oak was not on the
salmon
you're joking right I can't make this up
why is the egg not on
[Music]
the snap literally that
yeah
like I can't make this up
you guys
[Music]
okay so I ordered
a salmon Benedict which the egg clearly
is supposed to be on and then why is
this not even on the side like it's
supposed to be on top
[Music]
I really don't know who inspired you to
be a manager but I can clearly see that
you are not
you know the right person for this job
I'm gonna try to put this on if it like
opens on the way I'm literally gonna
have to ask you to bring you in
dude
can I get a new one
sorry yeah let's just get a new one with
like a new plate to be aesthetic for my
story
because I'm honestly not eating this
until you bring me a new one yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm so sorry you're like I'll just leave
you can just surf this to the next
person because I didn't eat it yet but I
really appreciate it
so if you guys didn't catch that that's
a vocal donation called vocal fry have
you guys heard about vocal fry
yeah I have about just about apps Peak
okay they're like talking to me like
this really It's gotta be on the egg oh
my God it's ruining my story like this
that's how dumbasses talk essentially
this is this is the Pinnacle I've seen
some bratty stuff show up in my timeline
um Ian miles Chong sure this is his
learn helplessness entitlement what's
even worse is that she chose to upload
this well she's one of these social
media influencers that's like oh here's
a picture of my breakfast and because
the egg isn't on top of the salmon and
the Benedict sauce isn't poured all over
it it's not aesthetically pleasing
enough for
so she wants to talk to the manager with
that vocal fry I've I've seen some
biblical levels of brattiness and
entitlement but I think this here tops
it for the week I need to get I need to
get some kind of like can somebody make
me some kind of like graphic Avatar that
I can play at the end of endless like
brattiness it would just be epic dude I
I I'm I'm chopping some chives here at
the moment and I made salmon last night
so I think I I should I should probably
comment on this but uh one of my
all-time favorite chefs is the guy is
the guy called a Marco Pierre White
and he is famous for somebody complained
about the meal in one of his restaurants
in London years ago so he came out and
he threw them out of his restaurant yeah
he didn't say oh sorry he just said get
out go on he came out straight out with
all the dirt all of him tearing up it's
so funny you like cooking right 50.
that's what I'm doing at the moment I
just got chives in my garden I'm
chopping them up and I'm gonna make um
eggs I don't know eggs with avocado or
home cured bacon or something
one of the hardest places hardest jobs
and hardest environments you can be in
is in a high-level restaurant kitchen
I've worked until it's almost it's
almost as bad as an uh
uh calling center calling center or
um a trading floor
you know like it gets to the level of uh
like uh Wolf of Wall Street
yeah it's that kind of debauchery
because it's long hours it's hard it's
tough there's little room for error like
every single mistake that you do
um ruins the plate like you cannot do
yeah like it doesn't take four mistakes
in a row to ruin a play it just takes
one one yeah and and it's it you know I
mean I I got I got trained by a guy up
in Massachusetts and
um you know he he the restaurant was
quiet one night he taught me how to cook
chicken and that's you know it's almost
my gauge on a restaurant is how moist
their chicken breast is and he he showed
me how to cook them properly and you
know he was weighing tables one night
and he came back in twice and he said
compliments to the chef on the chicken
looks like I taught you something but it
is it's it's an insanely intense
environment and when like that person
has no idea what's going on in the back
end of that kitchen with dishwashers and
supplies everything it's Mayhem back
there trying to bring that to fruition
and you know people have said to me in
the past oh why don't you start a
restaurant I said no it's wonderful one
of the hardest things to do and I spoke
to restaurant owners they don't have any
days off they don't have a day off
is certainly true
well okay for 90 seconds
for the margins
[Music]
um
ebitda which is basically
that translates into some other term in
in English uh Finance
um like the disposable income disposable
cash flow at the end of the year right
30 margins are not good that's not oh
it's not great for a business
turnover
well for restaurants a 30 margin is
pretty good I mean that's god-like
they're like they're not elf businesses
they're not easy or fun and Better
Business one more thing that I'd like to
add is that you have the heat
from the entire store from the entire
shop from everybody depending on you
because if your food is not good enough
nobody gets a tip yeah yeah what's good
about this though is is there's a trend
pushing back on these bratty you know
girls like you see it a lot in the
workout space there's this guy Joey
swole he does this on social media a lot
where he'll take these clips from women
where they're complaining about somebody
walking in front of their camera while
they're doing the set or somebody like
off in the distance that might look at
them for like a fleeting Glimpse or
offer to help them put the plates away
and then they make up some big deal
about how this guy's a creep or whatever
or why isn't here or why is he walking
from my camera and there's a lot more
pushback for that now so I think Society
in general doesn't have a lot of
tolerance for a lot of this bratty
Behavior there's probably a small
portion of Their audience where they
think that oh this will get me more
views or maybe this will get some reach
because I'm lecturing them or I'm
pulling the care nobody likes to Karen
not even Karen's like Karen's you know
you ask the Karen that's been a Karen
that sees a Karen they don't like either
I think one thing that hasn't been been
mentioned too is that there was a little
bit of like who the [__] is this [__]
from the waitress right you know she
just she just wasn't having it though
right you know and she's like get the
matter she's like I am the manager she
wasn't but I mean she's just like no I'm
not gonna put up with your [__] though
like
there's that saying the customer is
always right she's like no I'm not
putting up with your [__] the [__] out
though right he's going to get the [__]
out then right well let me think about
the type of attention that these average
that these women averagely get are it's
all about heart eyes it's all about
emojis it's all about you're so amazing
it's about how you're so attractive and
I love your stuff so anything that is it
doesn't even have to be to the contrary
anything that is just
not aligned with that worshiping and
kissing of their feet they perceive as a
slight
um walking in front of a camera so I
think I kicked it over
um like there are very few there are
very few people that record their stuff
at the gym most people don't do it at my
gym
um you know I went to a gym in New York
where people only did it because they
were power lifters and they needed to
look at their forms to make sure they
were hitting depth so they could compete
right but there are very few people at
my gym that's a you know that it's busy
all the time parking lot's always full
that really record themselves
um so it's a very small modicum of
people that are actually doing this so
to think that most people are constantly
looking out for your tripod to make sure
they don't walk in front of it it's just
asinine did you guys see that that
comment that Dan Bilzerian put out um
earlier this week here I'll put it up on
the screen real quick and for those of
you that are listening instead of
watching offering 5K for the best video
of someone soccer punting in idiot
influencers tripod camera while they're
using it to film in the gym
this is this is what the Internet Was
Made for This is brilliant more of that
yeah yeah we should crowdfund that you
don't even I'll pay for it I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out